hey Conan O'Brien here and this is the
live 360 pre-show this kind of
interesting we are now in my Warner
Brothers Studio but what we're gonna do
is walk from the stage over to digital
digital is where it happens let's do
that now and now we are entering the
digital world isn't this amazing you can
see various digital awards that we've
won that are unrecognizable to me
there's webbie's and it's an Emmy there
I recognize an Emmy and then this just
looks like they took it from a car I
don't know what that means
hey Digital gang Euro on 360 360 live
pre-show you're working on our website
right now Team Co how's it going a lot
of clicks and who's drinking this take
hava black tea who's had bleh why do you
have this much to hahvah is there any
reason for that this is a lot of Tejada
what I like to do is I get iced tea and
then I use the empty glass bottle as a
water bottle because I too much spending
too much don't want to hear any more
anyway
hello how's it going over there what are
you working on social plan for comic-con
means nothing to me
I don't understand it I know that you
guys do a very good job is it okay that
I essentially don't understand digital
is that okay is it all right that I I
mean the simplest be honest here why do
I have to know I'm just Conan and then
your job is to grind me up and turn me
into little qubits and send it out into
the ethernet right yeah the more if you
don't know very good let's say your name
into the 360 world Tory okay
don't be confused and Tory what are you
working on okay all right okay back into
the website now what's this here what
are you doing this is a hand lotion why
do you have the handles you have dry
skin yeah I have extreme I get headaches
look at that look at my it doesn't that
look like a mummy's hand that was just
taken out of a tomb after 3,000 years
the quivering I'm adding
in the digital realm okay you guys all
say that like you're prisoners prisoners
of war in North Vietnam it's going well
we are being treated well let's talk
digital for a second you guys work in
the coolest most cutting-edge part of
the business why do you have a stapler
why would this be even necessary
no one's needed one of these in like 40
years why do you guys have one let's get
rid of it why do you have tape
you shouldn't have tape everything is
unnecessary here this is oh my god
spry what is this dental defense system
well why is this even here whose is this
do we know who this is this should go
this should just be gone why do we have
a Mennonite farmer step forward why does
it you look like you just came from a
barn raising why are you here do you
even understand the Internet I do the
tech you do the the tech but that's all
you but why do you look like you just
walked away from your butter churn to
join us these are the creative young
minds that are keeping me relevant or so
they tell me funny when I go out in the
real world 15 year olds throw rotten
apples at me so good job everybody I
know that really do yeah they're doing
an amazing job I kid I make a joke but
we're going to comic-con and it couldn't
work without the digital team or so I'm
told I honestly don't know we probably
have enough I could probably sign off
now but first I'm gonna pour out Erin
Blair it's teh hava juice do we have a
perfect thank you for helping because
this is way too much to have a juice for
one man to have